ces petits fours et ce millefeuille
c'est qu'ils les ont réalisés pour le
buffet servi aux autorités présentes
lors de la remise de diplômes
au départ ils étaient dix à bénéficier
de cette formation de 500 heures depuis
le mois de mars à raison de cinq jours
par semaine six heures par jour trois le
matin pour la théorie
trois l'après-midi pour la pratique à
l'arrivée ils ne sont plus que 5 2 ont
été libérés un a démissionné deux ont
été transférés ailleurs mais pour la
formatrice le challenge est réussi
le fait d'avoir emmené avec ta gère
jusqu'à la rêvait d'avoir vu leur
évolution au fur et à mesure et le
travail qu'ils ont fourni cette finale
le chef pâtissier philippe conticini qui
avait animé un atelier de quelques
heures au centre pénitentiaire de
varennes-le-grand avec ces mêmes détenus
en janvier dernier a voulu les revoir à
l'occasion de leur remise de diplômes
l'occasion d'un échange sur le résultat
de leur travail qu'on a travaillé sur la
crème pâtissière pour pouvoir avoir
quelque chose de pas trop sucré
ok je vous dis
on a déjà ça se mange tout seul ça se
mange tout seul j'ai repris je limite
chaud à la maison et je m'en fais une
part entière un chef pâtissier exigeant
généreux dont les remarques et les
conseils ont été très écouté quelques
minutes plus tard d'été visitation plus
officielle avec les autorités de l'état
de la région partenaire de l'opération
titulaire d'un diplôme d'état à ces apps
et de cuisinier mais l'équipement de
l'avant sortir avec la possibilité de
trouver un travail
on est parti de rien ont finalement on a
un bon diplôme à la sortie
personnellement pour moi ça va me servir
parce que moi j'aime la cuisine est
depuis toujours même en détention j'ai
toujours fait de la cuisine mais on
n'avait pas les moyens de faire ce qu'on
a fait ici
ici c'était vraiment des plats tous les
jours on pouvait remonter avec en
cellule et je vous demande pas qu'on
s'est fait du bien monsieur continua a
remis aujourd'hui a tenu à remettre les
diplômes c'est aussi du sens c'est leur
dire que tout est possible le champ des
possibles est ouvert pour tout ça il
faut il croire
une porte ouverte sur l'avenir avec une
perspective de réinsertion positive